[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture le
magazine pour vous informer à des
actualités culturelles du département
voici le sommaire
la royale factory salle de café théâtre
à versailles propose pour les vacances
scolaires de la toussaint un spectacle
pour enfants intitulé la sorcière du
placard aux balais il reprend les
célèbres contes de la rue broca le musée
du domaine royal de mariée à marly le
roi organise des activités vacances pour
les enfants durant quinze jours
présentation du programme par membre de
l'équipe du musée et puis enfin le salon
d'automne à andrésy revient pour une
45ème édition du 23 au 31 octobre 22
peindre est inapte sculpteurs exposent
leurs oeuvres à l'espace julien green
la sorcière du placard aux balais et
représentés durant une semaine à la
royale factory à versailles ce spectacle
pour enfants mises en scène par la
compagnie tête en l'air est inspiré des
contes de la rue broca de pierre gripari
nous avons assisté à une représentation
regarder
c'est à guichet fermé que se jouer cet
après midi là la sorcière du placard aux
balais mis en scène par deux comédiens
de la compagnie parisienne tête en l'air
le spectacle est inspiré des contes de
la rue broca de pierres pétards à
la sorcière du placard aux balais c'est
vraiment on va dire un classique de
contes pour enfants donc c'est vrai que
parfois on voit que il ya des enfants
qui connaissent déjà l'histoire qui ont
pu la découvrir avec leurs parents on
semble que les parents ont à coeur de se
remémorer des souvenirs d'enfance donc
c'est vraiment on va dire un spectacle
qui fédère l'histoire est simple une
sortie rapide dans une maison et cherche
à déloger le nouveau propriétaire en lui
faisant peur et en faisant des parts et
avec lui les comédiens jouent ce
spectacle depuis cinq ans on a fait une
mise en scène par exemple qui reprend
des objets qu'on peut trouver dans les
chambres d'enfants on a fait aussi appel
à des masques pour mêler un peu l'art du
théâtre l'art par exemple de la commedia
dell arte pendant 50 minutes les
spectateurs souvent âgés entre 3 et 10
ans ont participé au spectacle
oui on a aimé
mais moi j'adorais quand le monsieur il
faisait semblant tout mais moi j'ai bien
aimé connaissance hier à l arrivée parce
que ça faisait un peu oui j'ai bien joué
mais me moment
bougie ou
j'aimais le plus c'était avec la la
première fois que la petite souris j y
étais trop mignonne la sorcière du
placard aux balais sera joué mercredi 27
jeudi 28 et vendredi 29 octobre à 14
heures 30 et dimanche 31 octobre à 15
heures
[Musique]
d'autres spectacles sont aussi à
découvrir en novembre à la royale
factory avec le one man show de philippe
roche et dieu créa la voie du 4 au 6
novembre tous les soirs à 20h30
découvrez ce spectacle d'humour musical
où le comédien délivre les secrets de la
voix un autre spectacle musical pour
enfants sera également sur la scène de
la royale factory les gloups mise en
scène par jean philippe azema sera
présenté dimanche 7 novembre à 15 heures
et enfin harry habitants sera en rodage
mercredi 17 et jeudi 18 novembre il
évoquera avec humour sa vie quotidienne
ses souvenirs d'enfance et sa vision du
couple
les vacances scolaires de la toussaint
ont débuté et pour occuper les enfants
le musée du domaine royal de marly à
marly le roi organise des activités
durant deux semaines la responsable de
la communication est chargée des publics
du musée nous en parle
[Musique]
pour ses prochaines vacances le musée va
proposer des activités
de pour les 5 ans jusqu'aux plus de huit
ans m 10 12 ans il ya différentes
activités qui sont toujours en lien avec
nos collègues
malisse était la résidence de chasse de
louis xiv on est en automne donc on va
faire des propositions autour de ces
thèmes là
pour les 6 12 ans va travailler
notamment autour de la saison l'automne
on va travailler en expression
corporelle
notamment autour des saisons donc qu'en
soit un garçon ou une fille on va voir
devenir une feuille un arbre on aura
aussi une composition autour d'un
atelier pratique n'hésita donc cette
fois ci on écoute vivaldi et puis
ensuite on est musicienne qui va mettre
une trentaine d'instruments visite à
disposition les enfants et puis on
pourra les justement pour les plus
petits à partir de 5 ans on propose un
nouveau rendez vous c'est un rendez vous
en famille autour des contes
[Musique]
le fait de t'accueillir les enfants ça
répond quand même à une mission première
des musées c'est tout simplement
transmettre partager l'idée c'est
toujours qu'il ya un mais qu entre ce
qu'on fait et le lieu où on se trouve
donc à chaque fois on va découvrir ou un
tableau ou une partie des collections du
musée pour travailler ensuite en atelier
c'est toussaint il ya un petit bulletin
à remplir qui est disponible sur notre
site internet mais si cela la dernière
minute on prend son téléphone on nous
appelle on accepte aussi si les ateliers
ne sont pas complets des inscriptions de
dernière minute up et il n'y a pas que
le musée du domaine royal de marc litt y
propose des activités d'autres musées
yvelinois ont mis en place des ateliers
et des animations de quoi faire
découvrir les collections à travers des
activités ludiques
[Musique]
et
ouais
[Musique]
e
et
les photos dialogue avec la villa savoye
avec l'exposition ready made se
photographier l'éphémère philippe
biancotto met en scène des objets de la
vie quotidienne dans les différentes
pièces d'habitation de la ville à une
première pour l'artiste ses oeuvres sont
sculptés dans la glace puis photographié
13,9 sont proposées tout au long de la
visite l'exposition est à découvrir
jusqu'au 12 décembre prochain à la villa
savoye appartenant au centre des
monuments nationaux situés à poissy
fait vraiment un dialogue entre le lui
la photo en fait la photo est vraiment
le témoignage d'un instant de grâce
ces pubs de la photo très étudiée
contrairement à ce que je fais en mode
où on éclaire enfin c'est très pensée
c'est très calculée c'était au cordeau
donc là je voulais quelque chose de
vraiment sans fioritures qui rentre
directement d'une façon frontale dans le
le sujet l'auteur j'ai dit à koto nous
incite à réfléchir un sujet très très
grave qui est celui de l'éphémère du
passage du temps mais il le fait avec
des clins d'oeil en démontant des sièges
en faisant fondre des objets c'est à la
fois très ludique et très profond
cela fait 45 ans que l'amicale des
beaux-arts d'andrésy organise son salon
d'automne cette année 22 peintre et 9
sculpteurs professionnels et amateurs
ont été invités à exposer leurs oeuvres
à l'espace julien green du 23 au 31
octobre regardé 5 grilles d'exposition
par artiste c'est ce que propose le
salon d'automne d'andrésy le but
diffuser plus largement l'univers des
peintres et sculpteurs présent ils ont
été sélectionnés scrupuleusement parmi
différents salons d'île de france ces
différents talents différents talents
parce qu'il ya plusieurs écriture
artistique à la remise avait de l'huile
de l'aquarelle du pastel
vous avez différentes techniques c'est
assez exceptionnel dans la région
d'avoir 5 5 panneaux pour nous tous
seuls est ce que ça représente quand
même des univers de chacun on a vraiment
le temps de rentrer en fait dans
chaque univers venus d'un peu partout de
la france mais aussi d'andrésy ces
artistes utilisent tout un panel de
techniques en hiver il est il assez
variés parce que ça dépend en fin de
compte des émotions
je suis très axé sur tout ce qui se
passe dans l'actualité il ya beaucoup de
choses et j'essaie de faire ressortir ça
de manière
poétique on va dire suffit hip hop que
voyez derrière
qui en fait a été fait donc à
l'acrylique avec beaucoup de couleurs en
fait avec des gratte et au couteau et en
fait je
ça représente en fait mon travail actuel
puisque bon je travaille avec ce système
de grades ajustements sur toile ce salon
organisé par l'amicale des beaux-arts
d'andrésy et fort de plus de 45 ans
d'existence il a comme objectif
principal de promouvoir l'art et de
donner une visibilité aux artistes
présents à l'art c'est comme le théâtre
comme au cinéma là la peinture la
sculpture et est un art un que beaucoup
de gens apprécient puis on est revenu à
une période pendant ces deux ans on
était très difficile et ça redonne du
plaisir mon contact avec les passants
nous permette vraiment d'avoir un un
regard sur notre travail c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle en exposant les
artistes s'y posent c'est pour permettre
d'avoir effectivement de belle
visibilité vous pouvez encore voter pour
votre peinture et sculpture préféré
jusqu'au 31 octobre date à laquelle un
prix du public sera remis au gagnant
et directions 1 mais dans la maison
d'emile zola et le musée dreyfus vont
ouvrir leurs portes aux visiteurs à
partir du jeudi 28 octobre l'occasion de
découvrir le lien entre l'écrivain et
son combat dans le cadre de l' affaire
dreyfus le musée revient sur plusieurs
thématiques de cette affaire d'état
durant la troisième république avec le
célèbre texte j'accuse d'emile zola puis
la visite se poursuit dans la demeure de
l'auteur de la bête humaine de germinal
ou de l'assommoir on écoute à ce propos
mme martin leblond zola arrière petite
fille d'emile zola et vice présidente de
l'association maison zola guide régis là
vous êtes dans un lieu
de 1 lieu de créativité
littéraire un refuge c'est un tour
d'ivoire cela arrivait ici au mois de
mai jusqu'au mois de décembre il
écrivait l'équivalent de quatre pages
manuscrites par jour ce n'est pas
beaucoup mais aulas ne dégage ne se
suffit pas de décrire il il dit toujours
qu'il veut bâtir son oeuvre comme une
symphonie musicale
élus musée emile zola est ouvert du
mercredi au dimanche de 10h à 17h30
réservation obligatoire sur le site sur
le site qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
et vous pourrez d'ores et déjà découvrir
le musée dans un reportage sur notre
site internet et nous visiterons la
musau là dans un an prochain 7-8 culture
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de nous avoir suivis rendez vous la
semaine prochaine bonne soirée sur tv5
[Musique]